[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain an american science fiction
mystery series called under the dome
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the story is set around a
suburban town named chester's mill at
first glance it looks like any normal
place but what happens next is going to
shock this quiet small town in the
opening scene we are introduced to a
non-local named barbie he is in the
woods burying the dead body of a man
barbie's injured forehead suggests he
got into a fight with the dead man but
the cause of the murder is unknown in
the afternoon barbie is heading away
from the town when he comes across the
sheriff's car it makes him nervous which
further diverts his attention from the
road when he finally loses the policeman
some cows block his way barbie swerves
the car and lands in a field with cows
his vehicle takes a spin but he comes
out uninjured a few seconds pass before
the town is hit by an earthquake the
people freeze in shock as the ground
shakes violently then all of a sudden
something drops from the sky in front of
barbie and everything goes silent a cow
falls to the ground after being sliced
in half by whatever substance fell from
the sky barbie investigates to discover
it is an invisible wall it was so sharp
that it even cut the houses that it
touched a teenager named joe comes to
barbie to see if he is all right he is
also just as surprised about the strange
invisible wall following that the
sheriff and deputy linda are informed
that the power supply to the entire town
has been cut off the phone lines are
dead and the internet doesn't work
either it is as if all satellite
connections have been lost at the same
time then an airplane flying over the
town crashes into the invisible barrier
confirming it is actually a dome and not
just a wall the following explosion
causes people to panic on the radio
station a dj named phil and his
assistant dodie are trying to establish
a connection outside they're confused
because they're the only ones on air
right now phil looks at the bright side
saying this means their ratings will go
up a fire truck comes from the other
side of the dome but barbie stops it
before it crashes the police arrive and
investigate the wall but its existence
is beyond their understanding the town's
councilman big jim also arrives at the
same time but is just as confused as the
others the group is informed that every
road leading to the town is closed which
is causing several accidents to stop
such accidents further they will have to
issue an emergency announcement
immediately somewhere else two
youngsters named junior and angie are
enjoying a romantic morning together
angie is also joe's elder sister who
works as a volunteer nurse in the heat
of the moment junior confesses that he
is in love with angie his heart breaks
when she says she doesn't feel the same
they get into an argument that ends when
angie spontaneously slaps him and storms
off
that could have gone better for junior a
family of three mothers carolyn and
alice and their daughter nori are also
visiting the town for work they plan to
leave as soon as possible unaware of the
dome covering the town another notable
figure of chester's mill is an
investigative reporter named julia one
morning she is called by a woman to
report suspicious activity the woman has
seen six tanks of propane being supplied
to the town's reserve this week it is
too much stock for fuel which she thinks
is being collected for an ulterior
purpose julia promises to investigate
the matter but doesn't think much of it
the councilman big jim goes to the radio
station and announces the state of
emergency to the people carolyn listens
to it but thinks it is some kind of
advertisement seconds before they are
about to crash into the dome a car from
the other side does the family is safe
but nori goes into a seizure right then
while she is unconscious she says
something about a pink star she is
immediately rushed to the hospital which
is filled with survivors from the
crashes happening around the town julia
and barbie are also at the hospital to
see her husband julia finds out that her
husband never works on sundays and has
been lying to her outside barbie meets
angie and talks to her over cigarettes
junior sees them together and is filled
with jealousy over time his love for
angie has turned into an obsession and
seeing her with another man triggers
something inside of him by now the
borders of the town are being guarded by
the military several scientists and
experts are trying to find out what
might have caused this strange
phenomenon but no one has the answers a
few hours later big jim meets the
sheriff and asks him about the propane
they vaguely talk about everything they
have done to save the town it is clear
that they know something about the dome
but they refrain from talking about the
matter barbie was supposed to be in the
town for only a day and has no place to
stay at night junior approaches him and
starts a conversation which eventually
turns into a threat barbie is confused
about what he did wrong but the
commotion is cut short when julia
interferes somewhere else the teens are
partying ignoring the state of emergency
joe meets a guy his age and the two talk
about the situation suddenly he goes
into a seizure and says something about
the pink stars like nori did earlier his
sister angie is in her house when junior
barges in and kidnaps her he brings her
to his father's old fallout shelter and
claims that he knows what is going on it
is then revealed that his father is big
jim he was always paranoid about her
safety which is why he built the shelter
in the meantime julia brings barbie to
her house and lets him stay the night
everything goes well until he sees the
picture of her husband and realizes it
is the man he killed that morning linda
and the sheriff are on a patrol when the
sheriff's pacemaker bursts and kills him
in the process a flashback from the
morning shows us that barbie was in the
town to meet julia's husband and talk to
him about some kind of payment the
doctor didn't want to pay which caused a
fight and barbie accidentally shot him
dead even though it was only an accident
he knew he was going to be convicted
hence to avoid it barbie disposed of the
body in the morning he notices that his
necklace is missing and asks julia about
it she promises to keep an eye out for
it but barbie realizes he left it in the
cabin where he killed her husband
somewhere else two policemen come
running to the sheriff but by now he is
already dead linda cries holding him in
her arms joe is with his friend ben who
helped him when he got a seizure last
night ben asks him what he meant by the
pink star but joe doesn't remember
saying anything after he fell to the
ground in the radio station dodie
manages to connect with the people
outside of the dome using a special
device she can hear the soldiers talking
to each other but cannot talk to them
till now even the soldiers are confused
about what the invisible thing is at the
town's diner big jim is enjoying
breakfast before linda arrives and
informs him of the sheriff's death they
immediately rush to the town's mortician
lester in the bunker angie tries her
best to call for someone but is
unsuccessful when junior arrives he
chains her down to a bed he thinks that
angie's rejection and the dome's
appearance are somehow related and when
the dome goes away she will return back
to her normal self the comment is enough
evidence of his mental issues the
mortician lester used to be the
sheriff's friend and is shocked to hear
about his death but when linda is not
around he and big jim reveal they know
something about the propane import that
happened last month they together with
the sheriff were hiding a secret from
the town the sheriff's death confirms he
won't tell anyone about their
involvement which is good news for them
later that day linda walks into the
police station to see big jim looking
for something in the sheriff's office on
being asked jim says he came to take a
look at his will and linda believes him
in reality he was there to find
paperwork about the propane import that
might get him and lester in trouble he
thinks the papers are in the sheriff's
house and makes lester get them
somewhere else julia goes to the radio
tower and finds out they can listen to
the soldiers talking outside the dome
through the device they figure out
people are trying to dig under the dome
but are unsuccessful julia broadcasts
the news to the town through the radio
the information causes people to panic
which in turn makes them irrational joe
and ben are near the border watching
scientists outside doing their job
they're trying to see if water has any
effect on the dome they reach no
definite conclusion but joe finds out
the dome works as a very thick sieve
later that day barbie goes to the cabin
to look for his necklace he finds it but
junior spots him right after he calls
him out for sleeping with angie barbie
figures out the guy is delusional but
cannot get him to go away they get into
a fight and barbie overpowers him easily
after that we see lester breaking into
the sheriff's house to look for the
papers about the propane import he finds
them under a drawer and lights them on
fire but the plan backfires when the
flames spread and take over the entire
house soon several people gather around
the house trying to put the fire out but
without the help of a fire truck it is
almost impossible if they let the house
burn down the temperature inside the
dome will rise and eventually kill
everyone barbie leads the people who
join hands to bring water to the house
linda hears lester's voice and runs
inside to save him she drags him out of
the place before handing him to the
paramedics even after an hour of trying
to put the fire out it only spreads
further then jim comes with a loader and
finally ends the commotion as the tired
civilians gather up one of the policemen
named paul loses his mind he claims that
they will never get out of this
situation and is afraid they will start
killing each other soon he fires a shot
into the air which bounces back from the
dome and hits a fellow officer he dies
right after and paul is arrested when it
gets dark joe and his friends go skating
he is approached by nori who wants to
recharge her phone he brings her to his
home which is one of the places that has
a generator meanwhile linda brings paul
to the jail while a crowd of people
criticizes the police system and
protests outside the station jim calms
them down asking them to help each other
in the time of need after being locked
paul goes into cardiac arrest linda
immediately runs to him only to find out
that he is faking he takes the chance to
push her aside and run away after
locking her in in the bunker junior
approaches angie again she has realized
that she needs to manipulate him to let
her free hence she tells him about the
closed tunnel they used to go to as kids
the dome might not work in the tunnel
which means they can go outside angie
hopes he will free her now that she is
helping him but junior wants to go to
the tunnel alone jim goes to the police
station and finds linda locked up
instead of paul he lets her out and they
discover paul is left with a rifle and
bullets linda immediately gets to
looking for the criminal knowing that he
must be in the forest where he
frequently goes hunting meanwhile jim
organizes a search party carolyn is at
the diner worried for nori she has
stayed the night at joe's without
telling her mothers jim arrives at the
diner and asks people to join the search
party for paul he also makes barbie join
them since he was a good leader when the
house was on fire they make it to the
forest where barbie shows his expertise
and reveals he used to be in the
military junior is on his way to the
tunnel when julia notices him she asks
him where he is going with the backpack
but he answers her nervously which makes
her suspicious she follows him and
reaches the tunnel joe and nori are
having breakfast at joe's house he is
nervous because he has never been alone
with a girl prior to this nori on the
other hand is confident and witty as
they talk ben brings in two more girls
to charge their phones he wants to use
the generator to impress them unaware
that it is an important commodity joe
has to reluctantly let them in in the
woods the search party runs into paul
who shoots a guy in his leg a second guy
stays to take care of him while jim and
barbie run behind paul in the tunnels
junior reaches the end and finds out the
dome runs through it as well he gets too
close to the wall which makes his
flashlight burst like the sheriff's
pacemaker julia comes out to warn him
but he is not happy that she followed
him junior loses his mind and starts
punching the invisible wall until julia
stops him they sit down to talk and rest
for a while julia tells him that she is
stuck in her lousy job as a journalist
because of a mistake she made in the
past as they chat junior reveals that
his bruises were caused by barbie he
asks her to stay away from the guy
making it seem like barbie hit him for
no reason by now joe's house is filled
with people using his electronics a
bully tries to make people pay for the
electricity that he doesn't even own
when no one stands against him nori
takes the matters into her own hands the
conversation gets heated but before
anything happens the lights go out nori
is happy that joe stood up for her
meanwhile in the woods barbie and jim
bump into their target but are stuck
because paul also has his rifle out he
is seconds away from killing jim when
linda appears behind and shoots him dead
at joe's house carolyn arrives and asks
her daughter to be more responsible joe
and nori hold hands which creates
strange sparks and sends them both into
a seizure they again collectively chant
about some kind of pink stars falling in
line in the bunker junior visits angie
again this time with a first aid kit she
helps him dress the wounds on his
knuckles but secretly keeps a pair of
scissors to herself in the last scene
julia and barbie are home after a long
day julia has started to suspect him
after what junior told her when he is in
the shower she goes through his
belongings subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching